the real breakthrough things happen
backwards which is Viagra penicillin
what happened was it was intended as an
angina remedy Viagra and there are two
stories about it one of which is that
the nurses noticed people on the trial
when they came in for their kind of
checkup they were sitting in a really
weird way and the other the other story
I've heard is that at the end of the
trial they were told well could you hand
back any unused pills you have to which
the response in every previous trial
been yeah sure here they are and in this
trial went
no there's also a f fascinating story
which is that a German pharmaceutical
company got there first noticed the side
effect and immediately rejected the drug
in other words any angina cure that
caused people to go around in a priapic
state of tence was obviously no good as
an angina medication and they failed to
see beyond it which is that